the nfc north is as cold as ever the
packers are the front and in the back
we're forced to eat tough losses
we're so hungry to win the division kirk
you don't always have to give speeches
you know our situation justin was
delirious
[Music]
hello rogers heard there was some talk
about you peasants making a late playoff
poor hunter
just use up my goodyear this is fun you
have to free this guy they say he's one
of the greats oh
don't bother i'm stuck here oh okay next
car what do we say to visitors
so please leave us alone we are the
scrappy team now didn't you hear
i stopped calling plays sent offensive
coordinator bill laser to stun
you all right i'm going to chance it in
free agency
i wonder if this is as bad as the nfc
east train this train is out of
it's the natural order packers on top
vikings down below
sorry we had to stop for the bigger
scarier afc north train
the standard is the standard
[Music]
so i says to him you coach my way or
i'll let you kick my ass stand clear of
the closing doors please
closing doors better stand clear of me
yeah remember if you see
something say something joe judge ain't
no snitch